hey guys so apparently this Cloverfield
movies trailer is being released today
in the movies coming out today this is a
really quick turnaround before our
anticipation the weirdest franchise has
ever been built yeah and it's also kind
of the coolest thing ever
hey I'm all for building out your
weird-ass fridge in very strange ways
and JJ Abrams continues to do his
weird-ass marketing man I prefer that to
just like knowing I to expect another
sequel soon
you know like surprise me baby hey
that's Cloverfield
[Music]
[Music]
is it the dude from inglorious basterds
there was it then in civil war was named
Daniel yellow and Daniel Bruhl and then
that guy who is a character actor yeah
yeah yeah that is is that Chris O'Dowd
crazy ass arm crawling around he doesn't
look like he has an arm in the shot no
it definitely doesn't that must be his
arm that's what they're all looking at
I've never been so excited to watch an
arm crawl okay this is interesting this
is really intriguing si Senor because
the 10 Cloverfield Lane was like I guess
it's a sequel no it's just an adjacent
app it doesn't even seem like a verse it
doesn't even seem like it's the same
monster that's involved at all with the
same there are many monster but this one
is a is seems like they're saying it
directly to be linked to the Cloverfield
part 1 and actually give us some answers
behind the monsters and the attack and
the invasion and all those things so
that actually intrigues me I mean
granted I'm really drawn to the concept
of kind of a semi black mirror thing
where the theme is always technology and
here it's like the theme is always
looking monster invasion a little bit
more into the future but it's not really
a sequel this seems like an actual
spin-off sequel as opposed to 10
Cloverfield Lane was it seems like it
has a bit less of a tenuous connection
yeah that is very strange but I do again
applaud them for doing strange and
unusual things with this franchise I
mean 10 Cloverfield Lane is one of the
cooler more interesting examples to
something I've seen in a while and this
certainly has me intrigued like I think
the Cloverfield franchise that's built
out of that has actually been one of the
more clever ones to do it you know
because Cloverfield is a pretty
memorable found footage movie even
though it doesn't like do anything
massively inventive with its production
values are so good that you know it is
great for what it is and then the 10
Cloverfield Lane is like a complete left
turn so yeah this yeah it's got me
pretty excited well this seems to have
the hybrid of that because hope
10 Cloverfield Lane is definitely more
of a contained thriller it kind of has a
home-invasion domesticate it's not a
home invasion movie but it's a really
domesticated vibe you're like trapped in
one place that is home asked and then
this seems like they show a character
who's looking at the attack going on at
at Cloverfield it is directly linked I'm
intrigued I am very much intrigued
yes again we've watched this tonight if
I didn't have to wake up so early to
watch the solo trailer yep 5 a.m. let's
do it
alright cool well let's find out why
they clover tower filled at least expect
a review for this movie out this week
yeah jump on it